it you know it depends on it depends on
the issue it depends on the context and
in the goal so you know one of the first
challenges is simply to get attention in
our fragmented media system you have but
you have the problem of choice it's very
easy for people to completely select
themselves even out of the general news
audience much less paying attention to
science so you have to figure out a way
to recast a complex debate such as
climate change in a way that is
interesting to an intended audience a
great example John McCain is doing this
now by talking about climate change as a
national security issue one of the
problems with climate changes that we
have a to America's of public
perceptions on the issues I'd like to
call it you have Democrats who are
increasingly concerned about the issue
and mobilized whereas for the most part
you see Republicans relatively
inattentive and and not really mobilized
around the issue in fact even dismissive
of the science but once you shift
climate change into the mental box of
you know you may never paid attention to
this issue before but really in fact
this issue is about national security
and it's about protecting against
natural disasters it's about making sure
that they're different parts of the
world are not destabilized because of
climate change or alternatively this
issue is really about growing the
economy around investment in renewable
energy we can develop renewable energy
we can create a market for it in the
same time we can solve this pressing
problem of climate change as soon as you
switch the issue to those two mental
boxes you're suddenly activating
attention from say a moderate Republican
audience who may never paid attention to
an environmental issue like climate
change in the past but suddenly they see
it as a national security issue or
suddenly see it in terms of investment
potential or economic growth
well in this case that you know and in
fact in the history on an issue like
climate change you know there's been
leading examples where the science has
been spun in false ways and misleading
ways and certainly that's been a
strategy of many conservatives to really
downplay concern of the issue and have
really no policy action always to say
that the science is uncertain sort of a
paralysis by analysis type strategy but
when it comes to science institutions
communicating with the public what needs
to happen is that scientists always have
to remain true to the science but that
doesn't mean that they necessarily only
have to speak about the science in very
technical terms that is often boring or
inaccessible to the audience so in this
case by repackaging climate changes
national security issue your first
activating attention and interest for
some people that might be good enough
they can take the issue and place it
along other issues that they're already
concerned about but for another part of
that audience they'll now be motivated
to pay closer attention to the science
learning only starts first after
motivation and you have to figure out in
part what when you when you frame a
scientific topic you're the first thing
you're doing is you're motivating
interest so that learning can actually
start to take place
you